i
have been trying so hard not to
mix up who i am with what i do and
trying to make sure that things aren't
results driven and so
i
i think i found great joy in realizing
that this was
this opportunity to share
that accolade with all of these
beautiful people and to them to look out
and see my wife and to see my mom and
dad and to see foster all of these
people that built me into who i am it
was really rewarding for me
i love how humble he is that of course
is michael at his hollywood walk of fame
ceremony back in 2018 and can i just say
i also love that et canada has always
been on hand for all of his major career
milestones speaking of the global
superstar is set to kick off his
exclusive las vegas engagement on april
27th at resorts world which is the
perfect way to gear up for his world
tour
[Music]
this is so exciting what does it feel
like for you knowing that you have this
coming up i wanted to have eight shows
and the reason for having those eight
shows was it was a great way for me to
work out the new material not just
musically but
as an entertainer it was an incredible
way to market the record and have people
come from all over the world and be part
of understanding that i've made the
greatest music of my life
[Music]
i had friends calling me saying oh you
did it you're doing a residency well i'm
not doing the celine they build a
theater do 10 years i don't want to be
in vegas for 10 years i want to be in
vegas for four shows a week for two
weeks and then travel to 50 countries
all over the world because that is my
honor and my privilege it's to go all
over the world to different cultures and
different places to show up in your
backyard and to be tangible because
you've changed my life and so
i love the vegas thing but it's just a
little it's a little chewy bite and uh i
just love working all over the world so
if you can get tickets to that it's
gonna be a blast
it will be
completely
[Music]
we have no doubt that michael will
deliver fantastic performances during
his very limited las vegas run but we
won't tell him that yes he has one rule
when it comes to performing my rule if
you come and do promo with me is that
when i walk out and i have a small group
of people i have you know the record
exec
who or the you know that somebody who's
taking care of me from warner you know
and maybe someone who does glam or
something right
but my my rule is
and you can ask my friend susan who
always always there with me she's one of
them
what's my rule sue's when i finish a tv
show
don't say a word
[Music]
i don't want to hear a compliment i
don't want to hear that was amazing
because you know what else were you
going to say we're going to say hey
buble you suck
and you know what that has to be way
better
[Music]
i'm not gonna tell you who it is
but i did a tv show years ago
and it's a huge big time star tell me
everything and we did this thing where i
came out to the tv show and i sang my
song i did my thing and i was okay so i
finished and my people were then we just
sort of quietly did our job you know
very hockey player asked do your job put
your head down you know what i mean like
seriously it's a very canadian thing
and then this lady
got up and she lip synced the thing
and she came off stage and this massive
group of hangers honors
popped champagne bottles open and like
like celebrated like they won something
and honestly i died i tried so very hard
not to lose it and no one loved her
enough no one loved her
where is their self-awareness
i need my wife at least six times today
to say mai you so stupid
[Music]
which she does for me she's amazing
[Music]
[Applause]